[музыка]
красиво природа воздух первый раз в
Казахстане гоняем Адреналин получаем всё
в целом хорошо будет круто
[музыка]
й
с
[музыка]
Если вы хотите с этого путешествия
получить Максимум Максимум эмоций
максимум удовольствия просто своё
ожидание Загони под
полни не знат
каждый отвечает на баг турах мы не
обсуждаем политику мы не обсуждаем
национальный вопрос мы не обсуждаем
религиозный вопрос Я заметил такую вещь
даже по себе очень часто ты мы сами люди
недооцениваем людей которые вокруг нас
но стоит Нам начать интересоваться как
каждый человек выясняется очень крутым
Он становится очень крутым то есть
крутизна человека вокруг вас напрямую
зависит от того как много внимания вы
ему уделяете если взять год с маргуланом
здесь сейчас Да мы всего сколько там час
полтора вместе провели есть чёткое
понимание того что вот этот вот
нетворкинг вот это общение оно делает
тебя сильнее и это стоит Ну очень
дорогого
[музыка]
B
огонь сейчас утеплил
плотненько и дальше без вариантов только
огонь те у нас традиция называется
стенка на стенку
а начинаем на начало и в конце
экспедиции это делаем тура первое Мы
знакомимся а в конце благодарим друг
друга поэтому первое сегодня
представляем
Магжан он пробивал маршрут планировал
места стоянки делал
разведку там все вот эти все моменты он
сделал так дальше у нас
Николай кухня Николай кухня кухней
занимается Иван кухня вдвоём в прошлом
году вы с нами ели
[музыка]
ша держитесь к ним
поближе кто вытянул бочонок вы сразу
идёте к своему Баги и там становитесь
чтобы толпу поехали
погнали это баги восьмой баги за
рулём первая половина дня за
рум баги до обеда
[музыка]
рута
во по-моему все у всех баги чистые
столько у меня пря смотрите разница прям
ну грязь - это вообще другое после Алта
это реально
другое грязь прям закидывает
нереально легко сложности Нет это как на
мотоцикле намного сложнее
[музыка]
с
Да машина чувствуется всё здорово Только
немножко холодновато но от этого даже
бодрит А вот когда сейчас ветра нету то
вот прямо хочется уже
достигну хоть у меня был лобовой он не
помог все речки которые были я все вот
так прямо пролетал весь мокрый
Нереально но это было нечто реально мне
очень нравится красиво природа воздух
офигенно первый раз в Казахстане
[музыка]
заливаться
кода Ну у меня спортивные машины есть
поэтому я когда на таких езжу это
похожее ощущение тоже самое концентрация
такой же ценность это в принципе побыть
среди высокоразвитых людей потому что
здесь все развиты добились каких-то
целей да плюс когда наставники есть
какие-то на любом семинаре ты одну вещь
усвоишь Она может тебе всё купить одну
вещь ради одного двух идей каких-то ты
можешь освоить Да можно какую-то дружбу
приобрести которая тоже отношения родня
поб нам
некая
медитация когда ты едешь едешь долго
сколько сегодня порядка 150 км по-моему
прошли И ты в какое-то состояние Вот в
это вот Приходишь как медитативное ты
уже ни о чём другом не думаешь ты
думаешь только об этом автомобиле ты с
ним Сросся ты смотришь по сторонам ты
чувствуешь эту дорогу и все мысли
мирские они тебя покидают ты начинаешь
чувствовать себя слышать себя
вокруг видеть природу вокруг видеть мир
Я видел сегодня сусликов Ястребов там
табуны лошадей коров Надеюсь Кстати они
были в реальности или всё-таки Я их
видел в медитативной
состоянии всё
классно е печка ба
[музыка]
бы прибирать
слом был классный Самое интересное это
было уснуть вечером и проснулся уже
только утром спал не хуже чем в шератоне
весьма было тепло утром вообще подумал
что уже прям потеплело вышел с голым
торсом всё хорошо только муравейник
рядом муравьи быстро меня
взбодрит удобные спальники классные
Спасибо А сегодня ночю я практически не
спал взял большую палатку Думаю будет
удобнее а во-первых она просвечивается
уже в 3:30 солнце Так светило что вся
палатка была
белая Ну и ветер жёстко палатка джала не
давала спать вчера классно поели классно
посмеялись
после дороги очень устали я проснулся В3
пошл искупался в озере сделал зарядку
Попил чай пока все спят супер Поймали
меня поймали
Да Слушайте отличная первая
ночь Как и любая другая ночь Даже
несмотря на то что она иногда бывает в
гостинице Ратон здесь я думаю было не
намного хуже даже наверно лучше воздух
был безусловно более сжи
абсолютно и настроение отлично Мы готовы
ко второму дню
[музыка]
го
что машина
бомба гоняем Адреналин получаем всё в
целом хорошо Мы очень
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
довольны
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
- а
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
а
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
vai
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
погодка отличная сейчас Заодно и душ
примем всё ребят по машинам
[музыка]
J
слишком тёплая на очень Да мы там просто
тели практиче было ожидание что она
будет попрохладнее что-то вода Да
подвела нас тели освежиться Меня зовут
Никита фамилия вахнин мы сегодня
проснулись на удивление почти все
выспались было неплохо спать в палатке
тепло спальники тёплые проснулись
позавтракали поболтали хорошо и поехали
очень сегодня был красивый день в плане
путешествия горы моря скалы было
интересно день был начался с начался с
Холодного подъёма но потом закончился
очень красивыми пейзажами мы столько
всего видели в степи Мне это напомнило
когда я в прошлом году плыл на лодке Я
видел Озеро океан и ничего и дельфины А
вот сейчас была пустыня поля степь поля
и лошади и красивые виды было
великолепно очень хотелось побывать на в
этой атмосфере людей которые прошли свой
путь может быть местами похожи своим
послушать их историю Рассказать свою
историю получить какие-то инсайты если
твой сотрудник не знает что ты от него
хочешь он не будет
эффективный раз Хорошо ты ему объяснил
что ты от него хочешь второе если он не
выполнит понятно тогда результата тоже
не будет И третье если он не будет знать
что он за это получит результата тоже не
будет Поэтому первое нужно выстроить
отношения между тобой и им Поэтому в
алгоритме прописано У тебя есть
маркетолог если ты говоришь Да там
Следующий вопрос будет а а у тебя есть
система мотивации маркетолог
замотивирован на достижение твоей цели
или нет и третий вопрос будет у тебя
есть цель поставленная перед
маркетологом то есть Поэтому ты должен
поставить перед маркетологом цель А ты
должен замотивировать маркетолога То
есть он должен чётко понимать и дальше
вопрос на его стороне мяч на его Ты
должен удостовериться что узко горос не
на твоей стороне
ты Поставил цель завышенную компания
миллион продат ты говоришь полтора хочу
чтобы продавали всё Поставил завышенную
цель и ты сказал маркетологу Сколько он
заработает
если компания добьётся этого
[музыка]
погодка наладилась пейзажи
потрясающие прям Казахстан удивляет
сегодня ночью кто-то очень сильно
храпел мы его вычислили но что он сделал
утром первое что он сдел он убра свою
личную бирку отсюда
ситуации неприятно дальне того что 2 3 4
5 у меня нету претензий очень радует
природа Казахстана Вот вчера мы были в
основном степи и как бы Очень неожиданно
потом было увидеть горы и приехать вот
вот такое прекрасное место но очень
круто Очень контраст большой В общем
кайфова природа пока супер топ вода
идеальная чтобы в шок прийти как тебе
сказать сказать что холодно
нет горячая скорее всего холодная на
грани кипятка когда ныряешь хочется
сразу оттуда выпрыгнуть Вообще супер
второй день все уже друг к другу
привыкли двигаемся как один один
организм чётко Не ожидал с утра вышел
рано проснулся
искупался вообще бомба давно не получал
такой эстетическое наслаждение
умиротворение очень доволен
[музыка]
о
с
[музыка]
H
моло ш проти
[музыка]
за
чтобы на улице тебя не представит
[музыка]
вы как бизнесмены Вы имеете дело с
людьми и
соответственно где узко горшка Как
искать первоя узко горшка - это в голове
у Евгения может быть второе узкое
горлышко - это в отсутствии маркетолога
третье узкое горлышка может быть в их
взаимоотношениях и четвёртое в понятиях
маркетолога
вот четыре узких горшка вот в отношении
двух людей теперь Евгений узко горшка я
ему нахожу узкое Горошко теперь Евгений
знает где узкое Горошко он находит
маркетолога и там проблема может быть
первая проблема между их
взаимоотношениями а Какие
взаимоотношения есть между маркетологом
и хозяином компании три первое хозяин
компании должен чётко давать цель что он
хочет
от маркетолога Например у него продаже
миллион долларов в месяц ты должен
поставить цель сказать Я хочу пол Милн
долларов То есть это как знаешь
представь как в ресторане Что происходит
между тобой и официантом ты даёшь ему
заказ Женя ты даёшь ему заказ он
приносит тебе заказ и ты расплачивается
три действия тоже самое тво отношение с
сотрудниками Ты должен дать Ясный кий
зака должен
[музыка]
рассчитаться спалось вообще прекрасно
отлично начал привыкать вчера ложился
спать и думаю надо же вот и к таким
условиям я готов адаптироваться вид
Красивый классно вообще очень нравится
мне захотелось встретиться с
номм понять Вообще как правильнее жить
потому что у большинства молодых Как я
вижу нормальные проблемы То есть они
сначала создают себе материальный Базис
да потом начинают думать о смысле жизни
а я совершил ошибку я вот с молодости
начал думать о смысле жизни да
и проявляю иному нездоровы
альтрум ком
в это не вери это кажется что просто
красивые слова ну и вот маргулан
Калиевич как бы дал практический
какой-то подход В смысле миссия нужна
для того чтобы отсекать лишнее Да чтобы
ты сконцентрировался на том что тебе
действительно важно Меня
зовут Фарид Я живу в Москве а родом Я
танат все
люди Уже целеустремлённые все знают что
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
хотят баги там уже есть настроение Пока
Хорошее но впереди дождь Надеюсь будет
недолгим не очень хочется сидеть часами
под дождём
[музыка]
а
вот мы находимся на озере шайтанколь
Это где-то во сколька километр
получается километров де от кар
каролинская но мы смогли доехать не
доехали буквально метров 300 вот пешком
сюда поднялись очень красивого озеро
сидим Кайфуем сейчас нас мся видами
ребята фоткаются ну это одно из самых
знаковых мест вообще вот этого кар
Каролинского заповедника много людей
сюда ходят пешком ходят Вот мы тоже
приехали посетить зафиксировать что мы
здесь были а сейчас отсюда спустимся
вниз и поедем на место нашей вчерашней
ночёвки мы сегодня две ночёвки проводим
в одном месте и будем готовиться к
завтрашнему дню завтра у нас 306 км
а
[музыка]
Когда я хожу по таким местам Прям
хочется вспомнить свою Юность я же
пчеловодом
работаю я пчёл люблю прямо сразу хочется
а медонос какой крутой Кай получится из
а
у меня это воздух не входит за это я
буду получать
отдых а мы думаешь отдыхаем или работаем
сейчас я учусь значит работаешь более
того ты занимаешься самой важной частью
своей
работы потому обучение саморазвитие
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
отличное утро сейчас наберём водички
сегодня длинный перегон 305 км по-моему
сказали поэтому надо настроиться на
очень плотную работу
всё очень круто круче чем можно было
себе представить вот эмоции валом
энергии валом смотрите Какая природа
представляете здесь 2 дня провести
вокруг этих гор солнце и что характерно
очень крутой компании это вот самое
лучшее что может с нами могло с нами
случиться это случилось впечатление
просто
великолепно дали от всего без телефона
классной компании
Тая энергетика супер просто 306 км дай
Бог
оделись утром были красивые сейчас будем
все дождевики одевать потому
что Опыт показал лучше всегда рядом под
рукой иметь дождевики потому что в любой
момент может пойти дождь и первый день я
помню мы через речки проезжали я вот
сидел так по колено прям в море был так
что давно хотел лично пообщаться
сном позадавать свои вопрос какието Ну и
безусловно мои ожидания оправдались и в
плане вопросов серии вопросов ответов
невероятная команда невероятная природа
невероятная организация мероприятия
очень благодарны и команда которую вот
собрал марла колеч ребята очень все
позитивные
очень хороший который вот именно с нами
наш маршрут сегодня 334 км это самый
длинный маршрут за время этой этого баги
тура
А наверное время в пути минимум 10 часов
минимум приедем может быть даже по
темника А сейчас ждём кухню чтобы
перевести её через речку а потом поедем
мы на второй день по-моему
утонули на двенадцатом бане ничего
страшного высохнут Ja
[музыка]
вы
надо либо
рассадить либо я не знаю Хрен его знает
нужно уже хоть что-то делать
[музыка]
парни едем с прекрасной командой в
прекрасном месте с прекрасными
мыслями с прекрасными
идеями ще класс
[музыка]
это вот как аулы когда в ауле вырастает
по все на мотоцикле катаются
дети уважаем любим А за что больше
всего человек
серьёзный серьёзным делом занимается
[музыка]
C
завтрак очень сы
необычный на обед был тоже очень вкусный
ктир это
признак сразу можно определить качество
повара по борщ вот Ну и конечно же ужин
потрясающий А когда ты занимаешься
торговлей ты в время работае с пото
Уно горделиво
торговца все торговцы умеют управлять
своим эго Они смотрят в глаза Они
интересуются другими людьми они всё
время спрашивают их настроение их
мотивацию они всё время пытаются
услужить и так далее именно за это
приходит вознаграждение вознаграждение
всегда приходит за управление своим эго
можете прям так ЧР начем круче вы
управляете свом этем боль васне
ожиданий полностью доверял команде и
лично рвану знал что будет всё продумано
и качественно и когда ты строишь низкие
ожидания и у тебя вообще не отсутствует
то ты получаешь сверх того что могло бы
быть Блин ну какие могут быть
впечатление Когда заканчивается Бади тур
одно впечатление сожаление сожаление
огромное сожаление что вот вот это вот
вся
компания вот эти наши путешествия вот
эти наши покатушки заканчиваются и Мы
возвращаемся опять в свой мир но чтобы
использовать все те знания которые мы
здесь получили все те как это правильно
называется инсайты ну я думаю продолжать
общаться самое главное самое основное
Вот мы вчера просто день эмоционального
Пика был и этот пик он был обусловлен
там тремя ключевыми факторами наверное
да там Первое - это мега крутая компания
это это это было очень здорово а второе
- это дух приключений и Дух какого-то
такого вот мужского единения классного
когда мы что-то делаем вместе Ну и там
третья - это очень классный предводитель
который вёл нас и наставлял это это было
очень круто Мне хотелось бы чтобы мы
поблагодарили нашу команду команда в
ответ поблагодарить Вас как гостей за то
что приехали к нам Итак начинаем с нас
на счёт три три раза произносим Спасибо
1Д Т
спасибо
спасибо спасибо
[музыка]
спасибо последний день всё последние 15
км было очень круто реально и как бы
больно грустно
прощаться как бы вчера мы вечером как
раз сидели обсуждали парке то что это
именно вот такой атмосферы хоть как мы
не хотели в жизни больше не повторится
Потому что всех этих же людей собрать в
одном месте именно в таком там атмосфере
такой вечером душевный разговор больше
не повторится как бы мы это всё не
понимали но грустно Но радует очень рад
что мы приехали такой крутой баги тур
был спасибо монли то что это всё
организовал
[музыка]
[смех]
у меня реально не было ожиданий Я просто
ехал и хотел получить удовольствие Да но
какое я не понял я ехал Блин я жен с
запросом поехать у меня был ини понно
тык тык тык влазить короче эти мои
запросы и я са Вот честно говоря на все
свои запросы Я получил и я даже получил
подтверждение наверное что мы идём в
каком-то правильном направлении Да самое
грустное что вот это именно вот этот
команда которая сейчас на данный момент
есть она больше никогда не повторится
все ваши впечатления отзывы это такой
завершающий аккорд чтобы очень важно
завершать
знаете любое мероприятие завершать таким
образом чтоб после вкуси долго длилось
потому что именно это впечатление потом
останется с нами Вот именно вот
законченное завершённое и такое
вкусненькое знаете поэтому очень приятно
то что вы все поделились обратной связью
инсайта эмоциями впечатлением мы как бы
ещё раз
вернулись назад ментально повс поминали
посмеялись и так далее следующий ещё
будет возврат когда мы у нас будет готов
фильм обязательно фильм на Ютюбе
разместим это нужно для того чтобы потом
вы с родными друзьями с близкими
периодически пересматривать смотрели
ностальгировать и так далее и так далее
поэтому Всем спасибо ещё раз Всё едем
[музыка]
домой L